>>
PIKE: Hi, everyone. Thanks for coming. Today,
we're going to talk about what it's like to
program in the new language, Go. It's different
from other languages. It doesn't look very
different. But when you actually use it, you'll
find that it's actually quite a bit different
to work in. And so today, Russ Cox and I are
going to spend some time explaining some of
the more interesting aspects of programming
in Go. So this isn't really a tutorial. You'll
understand more of what we say if you know
a little bit about the language. But we've
tried to pitch it at a level that even if
you don't know anything about it, you'll still
get a feel for what it's all about. Like all
the other sessions at Google I/O, there's
a live wave where you can comment or ask questions.
And we'll refer to it later in the talk. So
hold your questions until the end, please.
And if you have anything you want to ask,
please put in the Wave, which is at that address.
So let's start with Russ Cox to introduce
some of these ideas. Russ?
>> COX: Thanks, Rob. So today, Rob and I are
here to talk to you about programming in Go.
And if you're going to write a Python program,
you wouldn't start with a C++ program and
translate it line-by-line and expect to end
up with a very well-written Python program.
And concepts and the idiom in those languages
are different enough that you just end up
with a badly-written non-idiomatic Python
program. And the same is true of Go and other
languages. If you start with the concepts
and idioms from C++ or Java or Python and
you try to translate those line-by-line into
Go, you'll just be frustrated with the experience.
On the other hand, if you use the core concepts
and idioms in Go to write real Go programs
then you--we think that you'll get a lot out
of the experience and you'll be very happy
with the language and with your programs.
And so our goal today is to teach you the
beginnings of how to think about programs
in a way that makes the best sense in Go.
So just to get us all on the same page, let's
look for a little bit at what Go is and is
not. First of all, Go is object-oriented,
but it's not type-oriented. In particular,
inheritance is not a primary concept in the
language, and that there are no subclasses.
In fact, there are no classes at all. There
are basic types like int and float and bool,
and there are composite types like maps and
structs. And all of these can have methods
defined on them. Second, Go is implicit and
in two keyways. First of all, it's--when you
write a variable declaration in a function
or even a top-level, if it has an initializer,
you can omit the type and it will pull the
type off of the initializer. And because of
that, you tend not to see type-declarations
inside function bodies. And second and more
importantly, an object in Go satisfies an
interface, which we'll see soon, just by implementing
the methods that the interface defines. It
does not have to explicitly declare its intent
to satisfy that interface. If it has the methods,
it satisfies the interface. And we'll see
example after example on this talk of why
that's really important. And finally, the
emphasis in Go is on Concurrent programming
rather than parallel programming. And by concurrency,
I mean a way to structure your program so
that they can cope with having to do many
things at once and having to deal with many
simultaneous sources of input like network
connections, and do that in a way that still
lets you write a simple and well-structured
program. Now, it turns out that if you have
good support for concurrency then it's not
too hard to turn that into good parallelism
on a multi-core machine today. And Go can
do that, and it can keep all the cores running.
But the focus is really on concurrency and
how it makes it easier to write your programs.
And parallelism is just a nice benefit from
that. So to start, we're going to look at
a simple expression evaluator. And just to
keep it simple, this expression evaluator
has values that just have binary operations
on them. Now if you're going to do this in
a language like C++ or Java, you'd start with
an abstract class called value. And then you'd
have concrete implementations for things like
integers and strings. And in Go, we start
with "Value", but "Value" is an interface.
And an interface defines a set of methods
that must be implemented to satisfy the interface.
And for our values, we need two properties.
We need to be able to combine a value with
another value in a binary operation, and that's
the "BinaryOp" method. And the receiver is
implicit, and so the arguments to the "BinaryOp"
are the operation itself as a string and the
right-hand side value, Y, and it returns the
result value. And the second method that any
value in our evaluator needs is the "String"
method. And the "String" method returns a
string so that it can be printed. And if you
implement those methods, then you have a type
that the evaluator can pass around as a value.
And you don't have to explicitly say, "I'm
trying to be a value. So let's look at an
implementation of a value. These are just
integers. And for the most part, you just
write the methods. The first line there declares
a new type capital "Int" that has the same
memory representation as a standard int. But
they're different types. This is not--it's
not like in Java where an integer is a class
and has all the boxing around it. They have
the same representation in memory, but they're
different types. And in particular because
we just defined capital "Int", we're allowed
to specify the methods on it. So the second
line defines a "String" method on "Int". And
the parameter list between the words func
and String declare a receiver of type-int
X. And that "String" method returns a string
by passing X to "Itoa" from the strconv package.
And the rest of the slide is the "BinaryOp"
method for "Int". In the "BinaryOp" method,
the goal is to compute X op Y, where op is
the operator. And we know that X is an int,
but we don't know anything about Y other than
that it satisfies the value interface. So
the first thing we have to do is use a type-switch
on Y to look at what type it is and pick off
the types that we expect to be able to handle.
And in particular if there's another--if Y
is also an int, then we can do the usual arithmetic
operations: "+", "-", "*". And if it's not
an int or if--sorry, if it's an error, which
we'll see on the next slide, then we just
return that error as is. And on the next slide,
we'll see why. And otherwise, we create a
new error that describes what failed because
this is a failure that the left-hand side
and the right-hand side and the operator,
that combination is not valid. And so we create
a new error. Now, what was this about errors?
Well for error handling, we're going to create
an "Error" type that also satisfies value.
And so the result of the computation as a
value for that value might itself be an error
and it just going to propagate the error up
the evaluation. And so, again, this first
line creates a new type called "Error" which
has the same representation in memory as a
string. And the "String" method on "Error"
just returns that string. But it has to convert
it because "Error" and "String" are two distinct
types. And second, we have the "BinaryOp"
method. And here, there's no computation to
do. There's already been an error on the left-hand
side of the operator, so we just return that
error. And notice that in both of these examples,
we didn't have to write. We're implementing
value. The "Int" and the "Error" type and
the objects of that type are values just because
they have the right methods. So the final
piece we need for the evaluator is some way
to create values. We need some way to take
a string that's been typed in and create the
appropriate value. And so here's the implementation
of that. It's called "newVal". And it calls
"Atoi" on the string literal. And then if
that succeeds, it returns an int, and otherwise
it returns an error saying, "This is what
you typed, but it's not valid." And the evaluator
has a parser, which we're not showing you,
that just tokenizes, parses, and in effect,
calls the "newVal", "BinaryOp", and "String"
methods. So let's look at the demo. Here's
our evaluator. If I type "2" then the evaluator
has printed the answer "2", but it's also
shown a trace of what calls it made. And first,
it called "newVal" on the string "2" that
I typed in, and it returned--"newVal" returned
the int "2", and then it immediately turned
it back into a string. So that's not terribly
interesting. If we do "4", it looks the same.
But if we say "2+4", we get the two "newVal"
calls and then we see "2" called with the
"BinaryOp" of "+" and "4", and it returns
this new int "6". And then "6" has a--when
you convert it to a string, it gets back the
string to print. On the other hand, and so
if, you know--if we do something like "2*3+1",
the right things happen. On the other hand
if I type "X", "X" is not an integer and I
get the error back. And if I say "2+X", you
can see that the "2" got created, and then
the error gets created. And then the error
gets passed to the "BinaryOp" for the Int,
and it gets returned back and we end up with
"illegal literal 'x'". Now it'd be nice if
we have strings in this. So let's try a string
and it doesn't work. So let's fix that. If
we want to add strings, we define a new type
capital "String" which has the same representation
in memory as a normal string. And "String"
"String" method returns the quoted form. And
the "BinaryOp" is the same form as before.
We look at the type of "Y", and we pick off
the operations that we want to support. And
so this slide, we have "String + String" and
"String * Int" as valid operations. And we
have this "Error" type. And again, we return
the "Error" if it's not valid. Now notice,
we just defined a second method that has a--second
type that has a representation string with
different methods. So we have "Error" and
we have capital "String", and they both have
the "String" method and the "BinaryOp" method.
And they're both represented in memory as
a string, but I've pointed out before that
when you want to convert between two different
things with the same representation, you have
to be explicit. And this is one reason why
so that whenever you're looking at an expression
and a method call, you know what the type
on the left is, because there's no implicit
conversion. And so it's always clear which
method's being called. So we also have to
change "newVal" to recognize the quoted strings
that we type in. So if "Atoi" fails before
we return an error, we try to interpret it
as a quoted string. And if that works, we
return the string. And notice that, again,
we just added the "String" type by writing
the code that was necessary for strings. There
was no bookkeeping that was necessary. So
let's look at this. Say "hello" string, "newVal"
returns the string "hello". And we can say
things like ""hello"*3", and it does what
you'd expect. So if we step back for a moment.
If you're coming from Java or C++ or Python,
the thing that's missing in this program is
a type hierarchy. And in Java and those other
languages, the type hierarchy is really the
foundation of your program. And you have to
put it down before you write the rest of your
program. And then when you get halfway through
your program, a lot of times you've realized,
"Oh, I should have structured it differently.
And at that point, it can be hard to change.
And in fact, it's often easier to just struggle
along with a slightly incorrect type hierarchy
than it is to go back and change it. Now in
Go, program is not primarily about the types
and the type hierarchy. And in fact, there
is no explicit type hierarchy. And so the
most important design decisions in your program
can be delayed. And it's easy to change the
types in the program later, because the compiler
can figure out the relations between them
and you don't have to maintain that information
yourself. And we think that this makes Go
programs more flexible and more adaptable.
So, I've pointed out that we have no type
hierarchy, so we have no inheritance. So how
do you handle a case where, in Java or in
C++, you would use inheritance? So that's
the next example we're going to look at. In
Java, if you had a "ZLibCompressor" that has
a "compress" method that takes two-byte arrays.
But now we want to support a "Buffer", compressing
buffers, and buffers of some other type. And
we want to do this in a way that's going to
generalize to other compressors. So if we
have some other compress function, we can
reuse our effort. So what you would do in
Java is you would define an abstract compressor
class. And it would have an abstract compress
method with the bytes--byte arrays, but then
it would have a concrete compress method that
talked about buffers and implement it using
the byte array compress. And then we would
go back to our original ZLib and we would
add the magic words "extends AbstractCompressor".
And this is very common Java style. You inherit
the abstract class and you get the concrete
behavior from it that you want to add. Now
in Go, things look different. So we have the
same example. Again, we have a "ZlibCompressor",
it has a compress method that takes two byte
slices, and we want to support "Buffer" in
some general way. But in Go, we don't do it
with an abstract class. Instead, we define
an interface for the compressor, and then
we just write an ordinary function. So we
have a compressor interface that says, you
know, some thing is a compressor if it has
this compress method. And then we have a compress
buffer function, not an abstract class but
a function, that takes the compressor and
uses it to compress from the input buffer
to the output buffer. And this is good Go
style, you define what behavior you need as
an interface and then you just write a function
that takes that interface. This is easier
and it's less typing with fewer types that
in the Java and C++ way. And you could use
this kind of approach in Java, but it's not
common Java style because Java puts an emphasis
on using inheritance. But it's not just a
matter of style. Even if you did it in Java,
Go has significant benefits over the Java
interface way too. So first of all, in Go,
you can use as many wrappers as you like,
because the type can satisfy many interfaces
whereas it can only inherit one abstract--from
one abstract class. In Java, you can only
extend one abstract class. And a bigger deal
is that we had to go back to our original
Java program and add the words extends abstract
compressor. And what if it's not, what if
that code is not yours to edit? What if it's
in some standard library that really shouldn't
know about this new thing you've defined?
In Go, because things are automatically inferred
by the compiler, the compressor, the implementer
of compressor doesn't have to know that there
is a compressor interface. And, similarly,
the definition of the compressor interface
doesn't need to know that's enabling this
"CompressBuffer" function, and so all of these
types can be in these joint pieces of library
without explicit dependencies between them.
And notice that in Java even if you use interfaces,
you still have to go back and say implements
compressor, and so you still have this problem
that you have to go back and edit the code
and introduce dependency. Now that's one way
that you would use interfaces to do something
like you do in other languages. But I also
want to talk about ways that you use interfaces
just in Go in a more unique to Go. And one
of them is one of the reasons that there are
more unique ways as interfaces are lightweight
and in fact the typical Go interface has only
one or two methods. And programmers who are
new to Go tendency interfaces has a building
block for type hierarchies. They see it as
a way to get back to hierarchies and big classes
and they tend to create interfaces with lots
of methods. But we found that programming
in Go is not quite the right way to think
about them. When we think about interfaces,
they're often small and very precise and nimble
and often ad-hoc because you don't have to
go back and tell the other classes or the
packages that you're using these interfaces.
So this is a real example that we did a few
weeks ago. There's an RPC package in Go and
it uses a package called gob to marshal objects
on the wire and the only language that has
support for gob format is Go and we thought
it might be nice to talk to other languages
and so we thought, well, what can we do to
make this work with JSON? And so we can speak
standard JSON-RPC. So we abstract the codec
into an interface and the server codec is
shown on the slide. And the server codec says,
you can be a server codec if you have a way
to read or request header, to read the request
body and then to write a response and the
server will loop doing that for a while and
eventually close the connection and there's
a similar client codec. And then, when we
went to the RPC code, we just had to change
the signature of a few functions. So the send
response function used to take a gob encoder
and now it takes this more general interface
value. And, similarly, the function to handle
a request had the same kind of change and
this, basically, the whole change the RPC
implementation. We took the opportunity to
clean up a few other things at the same but,
in general, that kind of change is all you
need because of the implicit typing that goes
on and the rest of the function and the rest
of the program. And notice that we're doing
this after the fact. It's really powerful
that we can make these changes after the fact
and not have to plan ahead for them. This
whole change, the converting RPC, to use the
interface and then JSON took us about 20 minutes
and that included writing and testing the
JSON implementation of the interface and the
trivial wrap around gob to implement the interface.
And in Java, you'd probably start with, you
start by factoring RPC into this half-abstract
class and then you would subclass it to do
JsonRPC and GobRPC. But then you might have
to decide, oh, but I want to have the same
RPC server but with per connection changes
and so that would be another re-factoring.
In Go, there's no need to manage this kind
of decision or this kind of type of hierarchy.
You just pass in the codec interface stub
and you're done. One more example of interfaces;
we've seen examples of using it to structure
program and re-factoring and also to provide
abstract wrappers. Well, one of the most powerful
things in Go is the way we use interfaces
for chaining and for defining new kinds of
objects that all satisfy a common interface.
And so, in this kind of common interface tends
to arise organically. It's not something that's
planned, it just turns out that we have a
lot of different types that have the same
methods and so then it becomes useful to define
an interface that says, you don't have these
methods and then functions can use them. So,
you might be familiar with the "io.Reader"
and the "io.Writer" interfaces which are very
commonly used and have just one method each,
read and write. It's really important that
these interfaces don't need retrofitting to
work with the existing code. It's important
that when you introduce the concept of an
"io.Reader," you don't have to go back to
every single thing with the read method and
say, implements reader. So this is a more
complex example in reader and writer. When
we started to writing cartography code, we
noticed that, we have the first code we wrote
was the "aes.Cipher" implementation and it
was struck with the methods and the methods
that have were "BlockSize" which returns the
current "BlockSize," the encryption unit size,
and decrypt and encrypt. And, similarly, when
"blowfish" and "xteo," and other came along,
they mimic this set of methods. And we notice,
well, if we're going to write code that takes
an arbitrary cipher, we should define an interface
with these three methods and then it will
apply to all of them. And so the block cipher
package defines this interface and then defines
these block cipher functions using the interface
with things like "NewCBCDecrypter," "NewCFBDecrypter,"
"NewOFBereader" implement cipher block chaining,
cipher feedback and alpha feedback mode, all
taking this cipher and they're not tuned to
specific cryptographic implementations. So
if you want AES in CBC mode, you create a
new AES cipher and you pass it to the new
CBC decrypter. And, similarly, if you want
Blowfish in CBC mode, you can see what to
change. You just create a Blowfish cipher
instead and there's no need for this cross
product of every possible mode and every possible
cryptographic algorithm what you see in other
libraries. It's so simple in Go to compose
them that there's no point in providing all
the different compositions beforehand. And
this kind of chaining is very useful because
you can chain all sorts of different things.
So, if we go back to the reader example, and
you might have noticed that the readers on
the previous slide or the, they took a site
for but they also took a reader and return
the reader. And the reads on the return reader
are satisfied by reading from the underlying
stream and decrypting it. And so we can write
this function that decrypts and decompresses
from a source file to a destination file just
by chaining a sequence of readers together.
So the first line opens a source file and
then remembers to close it. And the third
line there, creates a new AES cipher given
the key data and then passes that cipher and
the file to "newOFBReader" with the key data,
with more key data. And the result of that
is a reader and that reader, that first reader
"r" when you read from it, the implementation
will read from "f" and decrypt it and return
the decrypted data. And then we can pass that
to a gzip new reader and then the "r" that
the gzip new reader function returns. When
you return from that, it will read the unencrypted
data from the first "r" decompress it and
return you the uncompressed data. And then
finally write, we open a new file for writing,
remember to close it and we copy from "r"
into "w". And so with that, I'll turn over
to Rob to talk about concurrency.
>> PIKE: Thanks, Russ. So, Russ has been talking
about thinking about programming with the
types and the way the types working inside
Go and how you structure program given the
kinds of things you want to do when you're
combining different types and stuff like that.
I'm going to talk about a complete different
way of thinking about Go programming which
is how we think about concurrency. If you're
working in Java, you start by thinking about
what the class hierarchy is, how you're going
to arrange the representation between the
items, and that's fine but it's not Go. In
Go, if you're writing something like a server
or some distributed program, you can use the
elements of Concurrent program that construct
the design of your program with a very different
field and, actually, a very powerful one.
And as Russ said early on, it's not about
parallelism. Concurrency is not about getting
all the cores humming as hard as you can by
doing Vector ops or anything like that. It's,
but is a way to make programs use multiple
for a machine as well in cleanly and easy
in a way that's really easy to understand.
The resulting programs are structured well
and they're very easy to change and adapt
as requirements change. So, in short, it's
about, the structure of the program rather
than the performance you get, but the performance
tends to come out anyway. So we need an example
and it's hard to do a really, you know, new
full on example and the time we have available.
So, we're going to take a very idealized one,
but it illustrates a lot of the points about
how this stuff works. So imagine you have
a bunch of processes that have work to do,
and they're going to send a request out to
some smaller set of workers presumably worker
machine somewhere that are going to performs
an operations for them and send the answers
back. In the middle, we want to place a load
balancer that uses, that controls the load
across the set of worker machines to balance
the load across all of the workers and keeps
it to sort of even load it. We're going to
assume that the workers work best when they
have a lot of work to do simultaneously for
whatever reasons just makes it work nicely.
If this is a real problem, of course, we'd
use a lot of computers and networking and
so on and so on and so on. But we're not going
to do that because that just makes the example
longer without really adding anything to it.
So this is a very simple model but its representative
of the core of something you might actually
want to do. So let's start what a request
is going to be. You're going to have some
piece of work you want to do and you're going
to send across to the worker via a load balancer
and then when the worker has finished the
task, it's going to send the answer back on
a channel to the requesting processing as
your result. And then in the middle of the
balancer is going to have some metric for
the load on the workers that's going to use
to even out the load. It looks a little bit
like this. Across the top, we have a bunch
of requesters, there's probably many, many
more requesters and workers but, it's really
hard to make slides that look like that. So
we'll just assume there's a lot more requesters
on the top. The bottom is a smaller number
but it still substantial a number of workers.
And then there's just load balancer in the
middle that has a single channel for all the
requests that are coming in. And then it immediately
forwards each request to the leg, most lightly
loader worker that's running, and then as
the worker completes each request and sends
the answer directly back to the thing that
requested it. And also although it's not in
this slide, it's going to signal the load
balancer, I'm done now, so you can adjust
the load you have stored from it. So, the
requesters look like this. You have a request
represented by a closure which is the operation
you're going to perform that returns some
type which we're just making into you for
simplicity. And then a channel of that type
which is the response channel so, you're going
to send, say, basically, run this function
and then when the answer is done, send it
back to me on this channel, that's a request.
And then here's a really sort of simple minded
but functional version of the requesting operation,
it just sits in a loop doing something else
for a while probably and then sends a request
in a form of close on a channel to the work
channel which delivers it to the load balancer.
And then it says, wait for the answer to come
back from the worker. And once the answer
has come back it probably does some more processing
on it. Now the worker is going to sit there
waiting for a request to be delivered now
from the load balancer and then it just sits
in a loop doing the obvious thing; gets a
request, executes the function of the request,
sends the answer back on the channel, and
then tells the load balancer, hey, I'm done,
and by just sending a point itself on the
done channel. And so this is very, very simple
but it works. And it's important to know that
the response is going directly back to the
load balancer because the channel gives you
the capability to tell the worker to respond
to you even though the load balancer in the
middle doesn't need to know, doesn't need
to keep track of the connections between the
workers and requesters. So now we got enough
to sort of think about the load balancer and
we need, we definitely a pool of workers,
that's obvious, we represent that with a slice.
And then, the balancer itself is a simple
structure that has this pool inside it and
then the worker channel, so that the workers
can signal when they're done; that can be
a single channel for all of them because it's
not going to be very busy. And now at this
point, this is actually the load balancer,
this is all we have to do. We sit in the loop,
and one of two things is happen; we either
are going to get a request in which case we
dispatch it to the most likely loaded worker.
Or, a worker tells us it's done in which case
we update the status of that worker so that
we keep the load sorted out, so that's very
simple. Now we just have to write two functions;
dispatch and completed. And the way to think
about that is if you imagine the load balancers,
basically, maintaining a priority queue and
the things that the head of the queue are
the most likely loaded objects, so we want
to order that queue by the length of the request
queue going to that worker and to do that,
the simple thing to do is to just write a
heap. So we basically are going to make a
heap of channels where the channels representing
the workers inside the worker struct and then
the load is represented by the length of those
queues. And to do that all we have to do is
attach the methods for heap onto the pool
type which is part of the implementation of
the balancer. And they're very, they're all
very simple--here's the less method, there's
a few others but they're all not, you know,
like, most of them are like one or two lines
as one is about four or five lines, but they're
all pretty easy. And once we've done, the
pool of workers behaves like a heap and so
now we just need to define the worker structure
which is has nothing in it but a request channel
and the count of pending request and then
an index which is part of the heap implementation.
So now we can implement, right? Here's the
dispatch. All of the dispatch has to do is
give in a request, you pop the element off
the heap that will be the most likely loaded
worker, you send the request, you increment
its pending count and put it back in the heap,
that's it. And for the completed set, it's
the inverse. You decrement the count for the
load on that worker, take it out of the heap
and put it back again, that's the whole thing.
And this is all working because the channels
are first class values and the methods can
be attached this pool type to turn the pile
of workers into a heap sort of post facto.
So let's show it running here. So this is
not very graphical but you can get the idea.
This job has 100 requesters and 10 workers,
and the workers are, the heap is basically
the pool on the left there shows the count
of the load on each worker. And then the columns
on the right are the average and standard
deviation of the load. You can see the load
is going up because there's a lot of happening
but the standard deviation stays pretty small
because the balancer is doing its job, that's
pretty simple. And just for reference, I made
a version that just trivially does round robin
on the workers rather than a balancer. And
if you let this run for a little bit, you'll
see the load goes up as it does in the case
but the standard deviation starts to grow.
At least, it does--here we go. It's increasing.
It's not nearly as even balanced as it was
in the case where we actually used a heap
or a queue for the worker, so it's just, you
know, a proof of concept that's not--there
you go you see the loads starting to go very
uneven across those workers. So, let's, so
to go back to the discussion here, there's
a couple of things about this program that
are interesting. One is that it actually works,
I've shown almost the entire implementation
just a little bit of setup is missing. Everything
that this thing is doing is synchronous. Everything
blocks and yet the system is highly concurrent,
and there's not also a single mutex in sight.
Everything is done--the structure of the concurrent
operations makes it possible to write a program
like this is totally non-blocking even thought
it's built out of synchronous operations and
there's no mutexes, there's no worrying about
memory barriers or any of that stuff. But
the fundamental properties of the language
make it really easy to write a software like
this. Another nice thing nice thing is that
this notion of a closure and the channel as
a pair. It's a really powerful idea. I can
send work to somebody and include a way to
get the answer back to me afterwards and that's
a really powerful structuring concept that
you see in a lot of Go code. And also you
see these channels being parts of first class
values that are passed around between different
Go routines as they're running, that's a really
important concept that's missing from some
other, not all, but some other concurrent
languages where the connections are much more
rigid than they are when you pass channels
around. Now this is a very simple example.
We can do a much more interesting case where
we had networks and stuff like that to distribute
load across many machines and they would look
fundamentally the same but you just have to
do a little bit of work on it get there. But
it's not really relevant to any of structuring
the program, principles are all in this example.
So, to conclude here, I think we've shown
that programming in Go is not like programming
in Java or C++ or Python. Even though when
you read the spec, you might think it's a
very sort of straightforward language. It's
actually a lot going on that feels very different
when you write real code in it. These include
the fact that objects are not always classes.
In fact, it can be anything including--we've
seen examples with strings of integers and
slices and structures, and methods are being
used on all of those things. And so inheritance
is not only, not the only way to structure
a program, it hardly even comes up. The inheritance
properties have gone up very interesting compared
to some of the other things we can do with
things like interface. We also don't need
to write everything down in advance. You don't
start by designing your whole superstructure
of your type system before you write any code.
In fact, a lot of the relationships between
types tend to come up as the programming evolves
or even long after it does like the PRPC example.
And because of this, a lot of things are discovered
long after the program is written, it can
be very pleasant. It was amazing to us that
we may implement a JSON-RPC but just substituting
an interface into our existing RPC implementation.
And Russ said just the 20-minute job, and
that's the kind of things it's very hard to
do when the structure of the whole program
is based around in here. And also, concurrency,
a lot of people think it's really about parallelism
and it's not. It's about structuring software
so that it can adapt and grow in a very parallel
universe. And it's not about getting all of
the, it's not about numeric competitions but
system structure. And as a result of these
changes from existing languages, we think
that was a very much more productive environment.
You can get a lot done very quickly because
things tend to be much more nimble when you're
working on it. You can give a method to any
type which means this all these opportunities
for designing your program that are very different
from a world where everything is a class and
you think of much larger objects are being
things that have methods attached. A lot of
the bookkeeping that you see in a type driven
programming simply doesn't appear in a Go
program. The power is still there but the
compiler takes care of it for your and that's
just a huge productivity game right there.
And then, this, it's hard to sort of through
big examples but I think I've shown looks
like this load balance, for example, that
concurrency is the way to structure a program
in a way that makes it really productive to
write programs that work with, you know, very
high load and very interesting parallel environments.
And as a result, Go programs tend to be very
malleable and adaptable and much less brittle
as conditions change. And, if any of these
interests you, of course, there's a lot more
available at the website golang.org. But the
most important point is that Go is a lot more
fun, the programming and, of course, it comes
with t-shirts and tattoos and stickers. So
we'll do a Q&A now but as you go, there's
a pile of t-shirts down there and feel free
to take one as you leave if that's the sort
of thing you like. I said as you go, we're
going to do a Q&A first. And as I said at
the beginning there's a Q&A thing on this
wave, live wave thing but remember to go to
golang.org for a lot more information. So,
we'll do this. So there's also microphones
if you want to do a live questions but we'll
start with the ones on the wave. Oops, can
you...
>> COX: And if you're worried about making
the next session, I think that everything
is delayed as much as we were, so, the next
session has not started yet, right.
>> PIKE: And there's enough t-shirts for everyone,
so you don't need to mob. Okay. Can you comment
on the suitability of Go for deploying a real
application today; if not today, what timeframe?
Also, my comments on server is [INDISTINCT]
with the mobile suitability. As far as the
first thing goes, we're already using Go internally
at Google for some production stuff so, it
depends on the particular job you're have
in mind but the language is pretty stable.
The libraries are good in getting better rapidly.
And for things that it's ready for now, it's
already being used for production stuff. I
don't know if I based the start up entirely
on Go now, but, it might, I don't know. So,
as far timeframe goes, it's just going to
get more and more mature, of course, over
time. But I think if you have an application
today, it might be the right language to do
it. For server versus desktop versus mobile
suitability, it was originally design for
server kind of stuff but it seems to work
very well for a lot of other things. The desktop
capabilities are limited because the graphic
libraries aren't quite there yet, all the
other are under way. And as far as mobile
goes, I don't have anything to say but we
really love to see it in a mobile environment.
Do you have anything to add? There's a question
here.
>> So I knew you have an ARM Compiler and
I'm just curious with the status, when I think
of concurrency and ARM, I think of interop
service routines for embedded programming.
Is it applicable and have you done it?
>> COX: I think that we're still exploring
how you would do something in a very, very
limited ARM environment on something like
the Android phone, which is also an ARM. You
don't have those problems and so we've been
running our ARM Compiler tests on that kind
of platform. We do have one developer who's
working on very, very tiny embedded things
and I don't know exactly what he's going to
end up with.
>> Thank you.
>> PIKE: What are your plans about port of
a loop go [INDISTINCT] between different platforms?
There are no plans per se. It's a compiled
language and so if you talk about portability,
you mostly mean source level portability.
We try to make libraries very portable between
different environments. It already runs on
Linux, MAC OS X, FreeBSD, there's a window
support that's pretty far along, and some
other sort of ARM embedded stuff. I'm not
sure what to say about that, except that the
language is intrinsically quite a bit more
parallel than language like C or C++, but
not quite at the level of Java because it's
one level back in terms of the way you compile,
but I think it's the right form of a language,
honestly. Yes.
>> Can you address performance as compared
to C, C++ and Java for server-side programming
with multi-cores? And also what if you need
to interface to existing libraries and those
other languages?
>> COX: So working backwards, the interface
to existing libraries, we have a basic tool
that let's you call C code from go and there's
also work going on to--I hope go up this week
so that you'll be able to wrap C and C++ libraries
this week. As far as performance, we found
that things that are highly computational
tend to be about the same, maybe 10%, 20%
slower with C code and equivalent Go code,
the place where it goes firewalls behind is
if you're littering your C code with things
like M-line assembly and send the instructions
and things like that, then we can't keep up
anymore. But if you're doing just sort of
standard portable C code and you translate
that into Go, computationally, it's not very
much of a performance set at all.
>> You did a lot of comparisons with type
languages or C, C++, Java and a lot of the
structures reminded me more of functional
languages like Haskell or Lang and I was wondering
if you could do a comparison with those and
where it goes--shines relative to these languages?
> PIKE: The functional language comparison,
I'm not a functional ad app. I think I'm a
little bit comfortable with them but not very.
The language has full closures and so that's
very nice to have but a lot of the sort of
magical type inference that functional languages
do are not available in Go. The Go type inference
is very simple, it's basic. In front of your
slides, you can draw out a type, the sort
of meta type of stuff that functional languages
have, simply not in Go. And I think that would
probably be the biggest difference in thinking
about them. Plans for not writing Androiding
in Go. There are no plans. I'd love to see
it but I--honestly, we're a pretty small team
and it's not where we're going. But it's not
an accident that ARM is one of the things
we support. I'll get back to that one. Yeah.
>> I saw a lot of you saying, "Oh, well, this
is just, you know, to implement this, this
is a bunch of one line functions and I think--it
seems like when you go inheritance to sort
of implicit interfaces, you find to yourself
writing this--do you find yourself writing
the same one line--the one line implementation
of the same piece in the interface over and
over again in a lot of different places?
>> PIKE: No. The [INDISTINC] we didn't talk
about which is embedding which replaces a
lot of that bookkeeping like stuff that you
would--that I think you're alluding to. It's
possible to borrow the implementation of something
else and drop it into your object and have
it--bring all the types along with--all of
the methods along with it. And that tends
to avoid a lot of that sort of repetitive--that
got to add this ten one line function to this
thing. I think that's what you're referring
to. Yeah. Current situation with generics,
yeah, that always comes up. We spend probably
more time on this one issue than almost anything
else. And the short answer is that we're still
not happy that we've been able to find design
for generics that doesn't break something
in the language or become to confusing for
users. So we're still thinking about it as
it's still incredibly active discussion. We're
very sensitive that we have language that
seems to work really well and we don't want
to mock it up with the generics implementation
that complicates life when it should. Also,
speaking personally, this is just me, Russ
may disagree. I don't--having used Go as my
main language now for almost 2 years, they
don't really mess generics, they don't come
up. The language feels different. And a lot
of the things that people want generics for
already sort of covered, not everything by
any means, there's a lot of places where to
be nice. But it's not clear that it's important
to go as it would be in some other language,
which is not to say that the word design comes
along. We would not go for it. We definitely
would.
>> COX: It's also--well, Rob said a lot of
people or at least a few people on the mailing
list who have written significant amounts
of Go code have said the same thing that having
written, you know, 1,000 or 5,000 lines code,
they found that, you know, they thought they
we're going to miss generics but they don't
actually miss them now, so.
>> PIKE: Yes.
>> You mentioned that there was a certain
intrinsic properties of the language that
make it easier to manage consistency of your
state in concurrent programming...
>> PIKE: I'm sorry. It's hard to understand
the...
>> I'm sorry.
>> PIKE: ...those things are terrible. Can
you speak a little louder?
>> Yeah, sure. You mentioned that there was
a--there were intrinsic properties of the
language that make it easier to concurrency,
perhaps rules dictating how code as it is
running in parallel can be interleaved and
how that affects the state of variables in
your closure, that kind of thing. Is that
a shortlist of properties in the language
that you could speak to now?
>> PIKE: Well, there's quite a few, but you
saw control structure in there which gives
a way to control access from multiple channels
at once the select statement there. The way
the stacks work in Go is they start out small,
they grow in demand. So, you don't have to
allocate a stack and say, "I need 10K of stack
right now or something like that." The language
completely handles that for you. You don't
do--you never think about stack size. And
they're cheap to do and recovered as necessary.
The combination of communication and synchronization
that channels give you, once you've used them
for awhile, you'll see it's an incredibly
powerful primitive. It's much more interesting
to program this way than by passing memory
around and using [INDISTINCT] to protect.
It's also a lot easier to get the code right.
For me, one of the things seems to--sort of
say the most is my officemate, Rob [INDISTINCT]
who also work on Go had never worked in a
concurrent language before, although we had
spend a fair amount of time dealing with C++
and writing server software and that kind
of thing. And he find--he's written a lot
of concurrent programs in Go now and he just
finds they work. He doesn't struggle with
the problems he had writing server software
in C++. And it's not that he's got a concurrent
brain. I've been writing concurrent programs
for many years now but this is all new to
him. But he finds it's really natural to express
what he wants to do with this independently
executing agents exchanging information. It's
just a very natural way to program. So the
language enables that and that's nice.
>> COX: I would just add that in your question
you talked about, you know, interleaving of
individual instructions and things like that
and we found that if you're thinking about
that level, you now--you just never get it
right. And what Go encourages you to do is--especially
with channels to let the Go routines communicate
amongst themselves of explicit messages and
that communication forces coordination. And
so you don't have to worry about, can these
instructions happened side-by-side, because,
you know, you handed object off to a Go routine
and now it owns the object and it does stuff
and then it hands it back when it's done and
there's no actual...
>> So there's nothing, there's no memory shared
between independently executing Go routine.
>> COX: There can be memory shared, but the
convention is that, you know, you pass an
object to a Go routine and it owns the object
now. When it hands it backs then you can start
reading and writing again, but until then...
>> I have a metaphor that I used to explain
this to people.
>> PIKE: Imagine you have a bunch of work
to do and if you're thinking about memory
barriers and concurrency, what you should
do is get a piece of paper and you write notes
on the paper and everybody read this paper
and you markup dynamically what people look
at. Everyone grab things when they come back
and they edit this piece of paper and it's
very easy to imagine getting confused by what's
written on the paper. The way you do it in
Go is you have a pad of paper and you write
down one task and you give that piece of paper
to somebody else and he can walk around the
room and give it to other people the other
part of it, and we're they're done they bring
it back to you. And there's never any confusion
because you're never looking at--more than
thing at a time. It's a very source silly,
childish way to describe it but it has a profound
effect on how you think about writing a software.
>> COX: So next question is, is there Go Compiler
for native client in the works? And there
is a Go Compiler for native client, it is
done, and you can use it to create native
client binaries. We haven't played too much
with hooking it up to the web browser and
doing interesting things with it but all the
compiler work is there and ready for playing.
>> It might have been because it was short
but Unix Programming Environment is the only
programming book that I ever read all the
way through, and a lot of the reason for that
is because assembling different Unix show
commands and stringing them together is conversational
in nature, that's important to me. I'm also
very event driven in my thinking. And this
language shows me a lot of--both of those,
so we're you specifically going for that feel
like a--did you have a cognitive model of
programming in mind that made this just like
field really right to you?
>> PIKE: Not explicitly but I don't think
it's an accident, you know. I have worked
in concurrent for quite a while and a lot
of it is inspired by the gluing things together,
model from Unix long ago. And some people
make an analogy between a Unix pipeline and
both channels sending messages but also interfaces
chaining things together like in the file
for example. But it's not an explicit goal.
I want to take the Unix ID and make it work.
It's a programming language. It's just--it's
a good model and it has multiple domains where
it makes sense.
>> So speaking of that model, the--working
with programs that seems to be complete when
they were written but you can string them
together. Do you have a model for sort of
external visibility of the guts of someone
else's program so that you can inherit from
another complete app?
>> PIKE: I'm not sure I know what you're asking.
>> Let me--like Tcl seemed when it was starting
out to be a really good glue language that
you could take stuff and, you know, embed
it, that's what SWIG is for. You have libraries
and then you have seemingly complex atomic
things that are good in themselves and then
you string them together in a language that's
more fluid. So do you have an idea for how
Go would handle the management between seemingly
independent apps?
>> COX: We're not really targeting...
>> Okay.
>> COX: ...that kind of glue. We're really
targeting, you know, Go--whole Go programs.
>> Okay.
>> COX: And we can interact with other languages
through RPC or through something like SWIG
for just calling a library, but in general,
you know, the shell works really will for
that because all the pieces are speaking the
same interface that read from standard input
and they write to standard output. And, you
know, in Go, you just--you have interfaces
like that. You have reader and rider but it's
all in the Go world and there's not really
an emphasis on interacting with the rest of
the world except through things like RPC and
that sort of standard mechanism, so standard
input, standard output, things like that.
>> PIKE: And RPC works in his world. RPCs
can satisfy interfaces and, you know, channels
can be passed over networks and I think there's
higher level of things that go on, but I don't
think it's exactly what you're getting at.
>> I'm just wondering, is there some model
for like, for sharing code like, I mean, Ruby
has, like, you know, gems and it's easy to,
like, I think when something, someone is done
or like Java jars and...
>> COX: Sure. There's a program in the distribution
called Go Install and you can think of it
as sort of a distributed CPAN, basically,
if you put your code on GitHub or Google code
or one of these code hosting sites. Then you
can say "goinstall" and give it a path of
the right form and it will install that package
and then you just import it.
>> So does it, like, does it have to be in
the source code format or I mean...
>> COX: Yes.
>> Yeah?
>> COX: Yup.
>> So you can't do a binary.
>> COX: At the moment no. I mean you're compiling
for many different architectures, right? So
the binary would limit you to just the person
who, you know, has the same machine that you
do.
>> Thanks.
>> Well, I was looking at the slide there,
I didn't quite see--if you have a bunch of
libraries together, how do you make sure the
name spacing doesn't clash? Is there some
sort of name space or scope...?
>> COX: There's no uniqueness in the name
space, so if it does clash all you have to
do is rename one of them during the import
for your particular file and then, you know,
it'll--you can use the different names to
refer within that file. And the linker and
the compiler and all these tools can handle
the fact that there might be multiple files,
let's say, I mean pack and hash as long as
they have different import paths, they're
different, they're different packages. So,
it all just works.
>> Okay. Excellent.
>> PIKE: There's no such thing as a truly
global name in Go.
>> Okay.
>> PIKE: Every name is relative to a package
and even if packages have the same name, they
are distinct and entities in the world and
you can resolve it.
>> All right. And my other question was, I
saw that you had something like defer I/O.close,
what exactly was that?
>> COX: Defer is a concept in the language
that says, "Right before you return run this
function call." And so when I said "deferf.close"
what it meant is that no matter how you return
from this function call "f.close" as you go.
>> PIKE: And that's a dynamic call, it's not
scope. So, you could call "deferf.close" for
five different values of "F" and it would
close all five "Fs". So if you have loop opening
file then you said defer call that close in
that loop, it will close all of it. So, it's
not a scope thing, it's a dynamic thing.
>> So I suppose this language is not statically
typed, that's right, isn't it?
>> PIKE: No, it's statically typed but it
has some dynamic typing depending on how you're
using interfaces. Sometimes narrowing has
to be done dynamically.
>> Okay. But comparing it to Java a lot of
checking can be done in Java in compile time.
>> COX: Go is very statically typed. All of
the programs that we're looking at were using
interfaces; and interfaces, even interfaces
are statically typed. So where there was a
parameter of typed value there can only be
an object that has the right value methods.
But you could also have a parameter of type
end, bull or float just like in Java and so...
>> But the point is that you can't check everything.
You could check in Java at compile time, isn't
that right? Because if you pass in an object
which might be of the right...
>> COX: I believe that you can check--everything
you can check in Java and Go in compile time.
>> In compile time?
>> COX: It's very static, and the compiler--if
you're not being careful with the types, if
there's something the compiler cannot prove
but it needs to know, it requires you to be
very explicit and say, "I'm promising here
and I understand this could be a runtime check
and runtime false." And so it's very much
statically typed and you can use interfaces
to make it feel much more dynamic but in the
compiler it's al static.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> So I've been using Go for he past couple
of months, and it seems like a lot of the
work is, like, making it more stable in fixing
bugs. Are there any new features of the language,
you guys, are planning to add? Like, I personally
like to see more of dynamic features like
being able to, like, manipulate types more.
Is there anything you guys are planning to...?
>> PIKE: I think roadmap has some things but
not in a general direction. I think there's
probably coming a time when dynamic code loading
would be available, but there's no plan for
that. We haven't talk about it. I just sort
of given a way the packages or work in a structure
of things. I think that's got to develop on
its own. At the moment we're more concern
with developing libraries to the point that
people can use this for production in more
ways. But, you know, rose up in the proposals,
so if you got things you want to talk about,
you know, let us know and we'll consider it.
>> COX: I also think that language changes
just take longer. They take a long time to
just simmer and really come up with a good
design and it takes a while to roll out. And
so you're going to see fewer of them than
you see, you know, new libraries. And so in
particular the reason it changes to panic
in the introduction of a cover were things
that we spend a very long time thinking about
on the back burner before we finally came
over the design that we liked and then it
was relative and quick to roll out and so
it's mostly design.
>> PIKE: Two years of thinking before it went
in, so.
>> COX: And as far as what you were talking
about for types in particular, I think that
the reflect package is probably in need of
redo. And I think that when we do that you
might see some more dynamic key things like
you should be able to just construct the type
at runtime I think. But all of that is still
very much just simmering in the back and eventually
it will, you know, bubble over and will have
some thing.
>> PIKE: One thing we didn't mention because
as I've said this is a tutorial is there is
full runtime reflection for those who don't
know that, which makes for some really interesting
possibilities. Any questions? How are we on
time? I can't see the clock back there.
>> COX: It says eight minutes.
>> PIKE: Eight minutes. Okay.
>> You mentioned about RPC...
>> PIKE: Can you take--can you come to the
mic if you're going to ask us a question?
>> So graphics processors are really powerful,
is there plans or something...
>> COX: Can you speak up? I'm sorry.
>> Is there plans for something like open
CL, you know, to run stuff on the graphics
processors?
>> COX: Graphics processors. There are no
plans but hopes and dreams sure.
>> All right. You mentioned RPC for inter-program
language stuff. Google uses protobuffs and
you have internal RPCs, what about for other
RPC systems, they're like co-generation for
thrift which does provide RPC right now or
is that something you could provide?
>> COX: We don't, but I think that changes
to RPC that we talked about here would--that
made it possible to plug-in JSON RPC as the
wiring coding. I think you can plug-in protocol
buffer wiring coding. I think you could plug-in
thrift wiring coding and just use the standard
Go RPC server and you could speak all of those
protocols at once if you wanted to.
>> All right.
>> COX: Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> PIKE: It's really straightforward to swap
the encoding app.
>> What's the policy on what goes into the
standard binary package versus external? I've
seen a whole bunch of stuff that's in the
standard Go and I've seen languages like Perl
and Python that have grown a really large
standard library, then I had to got it or
clean it up later.
>> PIKE: We're very, very sensitive with that
issue because we think that some other languages,
I won't name them, but I think some other
languages have not been careful enough about
how the library goes. So, we've been trying
to make sure that the basic libraries that
are installed with the compiler and stuff
when you get it form a really good corset
that large subset of which will be use in
most programs. And things that are much more
special purpose or larger in scope, we tend
to encourage people to make separate repositories
for but then in turn we have a program "Go
Install" which makes it very easy to import
them if you want. We want to make sure that
the standard packages were useful, modest
and scoped but--and very, very well written.
>> COX: I even put in something in the standard
library as a promise that, you know, something
like this is going to stay there and so I
think we have to be careful just to think
about, you know, is that general enough that...
>> But you just mentioned redoing the reflect
package for instance.
>> COX: I'm sorry.
>> You mentioned redoing the reflect package.
>> COX: Right. But I think it's a promise
about the functionality more than the details
of the interface. So, for example, you know,
someone wrote fuse package recently, and I
think fuses are good example, something that
makes sense as a separate package and you
can "Go Install" it and so it's no harder
to use than the regular packages. But it,
you know, it doesn't really makes sense in
those standard tree. I think once Go is a
little bit more mature, we might see people
who build Go distributions that have a whole
bunch of other packages pulled in, you know,
just as part of the tree as though they'd
already been "Go Install."
>> PIKE: Right.
>> COX: But I think the standard stuff is
really supposed to be the kind of things you'd
expect in a standard library.
>> PIKE: And "Go Install" works transitive
so it makes [INDISTINCT]. So we've only got
few seconds left, so are there--I think there's
no more questions. Thanks everyone for coming
and grab your flag on the way out.